-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We are back in the studio
and we hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
When asked last week by
reporters if he was confident
that he could get voting rights
legislation passed,
President Biden said, quote,
"I hope we can get this done,
but I'm not sure."
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Quite a turn from
the "yes we can" days.
It's like Nike changing
their slogan to,
"I dunno.
Go for it if you want."
[ Laughter ]
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
volunteered
at a food bank yesterday
and wore
a Philadelphia Eagles T-shirt,
which was a nice way of showing
she understands pain
and hardship.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Donald Trump
held his first rally of the year
over the weekend in Arizona
and is already back
to telling lies.
-I love Arizona.
-Come on.
[ Laughter ]
The CDC is reportedly
experiencing
a massive wave of staff burnout,
and even that was reported
two weeks late.
[ Laughter ]
Americans will be able to order
free at-home rapid
coronavirus tests
from the federal government
this week
and, in equally timely news,
2020 New Year's glasses.
[ Laughter ]
We like to get you the tests
after the wave.
Former President Trump has
reportedly been complaining
to confidants about
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
and said he has a, quote,
"dull personality."
I'm sorry, that's suddenly
a concern of yours?
Your vice president
was like if a rice cake
went to Bible school.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Senator Mitt Romney
warned in a new interview
that Russian president
Vladimir Putin
is attempting to weaken
the NATO alliance
and re-create the Soviet Union.
Oh, thanks, Mitt.
Mitt Romney is like a dad
who wanders in
while you're watching
Harry Potter and says,
"That Voldemort fella looks like
bad news to me."
"We know, Dad!
Get out!"
[ Laughter ]
DIRECTV announced on Friday
that it will drop
the far-right television channel
One America News
from its service once
its current contract expires,
or sooner
if it rains really hard.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, thought that was going to
be a joke about OAN,
but we went after DIRECTV.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida Republican who lost a
congressional special election
last week by 59 points
is refusing to concede the race.
But eventually he'll have to
go back to his old job
as Florida's
Math Teacher of the Year.
[ Laughter ]
Hopefully, people watching this
on DIRECTV
got some really hard rain
before that joke.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new study,
playing a tape recording
of people's names while sleeping
can improve name recall
the next day.
So, shout-out to my writers Ian,
Brian, and turn tape over.
[ Laughter ]
So, there was a new study about
an old-timey tape player?
I'm not so sure about that.
That was the monologue,
everybody.